you
I've been winning cherry I'm on chess
calms tactics trainer and I'm going to
work my way through three puzzles and
just share my thoughts along the way
what is this first puzzle
Wow doesn't get too much more simplified
than this what is the big idea we're
supposed to win or draw this how how do
we do that
[Music]
okay let's just try pushing the pond our
pond is faster if we play a 401 I'm a
four D for a five blacks going to Queen
first we clean next to draw if we play a
four King B 4 and what are we doing that
this puzzle so far I must admit is
making me feel really stupid there
aren't so many candidate moves going to
be a king move or a bad move
Oh what does this do what does this do
hit my feet
b6 ah it is and will happen what's going
to happen I believe is black will get a
queen and then we'll be on move with the
pawn on a6 will push I wouldn't work
because the Queen will be able to
control a a it should play to d5 let's
see I think it might be king b6 now
that's not working
King bee 6 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 and then
blacks next move will be a bee to get on
this diagonal and stop the pond so what
does this mean means we have to play a
four I move one a for King B 4 and then
King B 6
okay a for force the King to make a move
first and then King to be six okay we
need to make the King commit first move
order move order move order that's
pretty sneaky puzzle okay
a for King B for and the idea here is
King be six if King takes pawn king c5
would hunt down the pond and out it's
just a race where black Queens white
Queens and this will be a drawn endgame
mmm okay let's try puzzle too weird
start team white for this one
oh we're just so close to queening can
we force this through somehow the rook
is the only one stopping FA equals Queen
okay well we have some mating tricks I
believe why
five and if the King goes to the seventh
rank we promote with the discovered
check so if we start off with b5 and
this really should be the first one I'm
considering b5 King b6 what do you do
there
follow up check of rook here I don't
know what that really accomplishes
you
King goes to b7 I don't see the
follow-up b5 King b6 Bishop takes pawn
if rip takes we promote b5 King b6
Bishop takes pawn King takes Bishop what
do we have there ah we do have something
the King in the record on the same rank
so we play rook here we're giving up a
lot of material though just to get a
queen but then again from this position
we are down a minor piece have a pawn
for it
I don't know we'd end up with a queen
right sure the rook Knight Queen versus
a rook and I am Bishop b5 King b6 Bishop
takes pawn I mean this one is hit twice
if we're not Swift just rook takes pawn
and we got nothing
b5 king b6 Bishop takes pawn check King
takes
now we get a piece after rook here rook
takes rook pawn push is with check
hitting the king in the night so it end
up in a position where it's our clean
versus a rook and Bishop I think that
that's the best we could do let's see
anything else they should take c5 yep
and now this move get a queen puzzle
salt well we stopped upon in the
position - yeah I forgot about that guy
he's important why he'll go on to win
this taking up the night yeah let me
just take it out a couple more moves so
let's just put this on
g5 rook takes we get a queen and yeah if
you go here we take the night with check
so may even be something yeah may even
be something better we know you about to
take the night I guess we go after the
rook the King goes here there's Queen
here probably multiple ways to win it we
could probably take the night and be
winning yes or even go here
okay that's pretty slick v5 first and as
mentioned if the King goes here we
promote discovery check okay team light
Oh multiple checks present any Rick
movers check bishop check here not the
first one I'm looking into we could
always win the Queen
but I feel like we should be able to
make here where's the main feels like
there should be a mate rook - maybe we
just win the Queen she is unprotected at
the very least 57 we win a full/queen so
next best would be killing the king yeah
let's see let's see
rook d7 you can always get the Queen but
where's the may now rook g8 can you go
to one of these - Queen g7v
okay
last one
and pawn one okay that was an a in to
that last one
okay we can't win this
Kings going to get to g4 and he's going
to win this pawn the trick here is to
somehow take opposition
so how do we pull this off how we don't
pull this off is by playing a five
because he mops up this pond and then
this pond next and there's a pond in
reserve black pond that could always
move in lacking it the opposition back
if black can get the black can get the
opposition if he he wants to so what's
the idea probably to approach with the
king he is going to be a king mo or is
it yeah I think it's a king move with
some what some idea I believe to maybe
pitch upon and force this guy forward
you
and it may be g6 on move on let's see if
g6 and King takes pawn that's that's a
that's a simple drop because King g2
King f3 and they're not even getting
this pawn and even if they do by that
point there's a way to take opposition
so on g6 King takes I know to do there I
know how to draw that
push context on we can't allow the
to take the pond there I think this is
actually the sack of both ponds is a
clever puzzle so it's sometimes really
interesting to see how few pieces can
have some depth to them g6 context and I
believe next we have to play f5 notice
because the pawn is creeping a little
bit closer these ideas to have a like a
tempo with a pawn advance or you know
they're not going to be there in this
kind of an ending with the King and pawn
end games you know trying to promote a
pawn ideally you want your king out in
front of the pawn
g6 the pun is creeping a little bit
closer to the king f5 pawn takes pawn
the king is no longer in front of the
pond and in that position we would play
what
kingi one approaching with kingi to
allows king here taking opposition king
h2 allows King h4 taking up position the
solution must be g6 takes f5 takes King
g1 if King g5 then King f1 put it on
that's correct we have to do like this
and we have to go to g1 there's only
three legal moves but here there's King
g4 here this King h4 have to go here and
on that move I was saying King here and
I believe I still am correct on that yes
have to go to f1 going here allows here
to here and the King is getting out in
front of the pawn king f1 must and on
that move now we can take opposition and
the puzzle is solved let me just dive
into that original position once more
because I know I was not helpful when I
just said okay I know what to do if King
takes pawn in this position here's how
it may play out let's say King here here
here here actually we're not even going
to be getting the pond black black won't
be even getting the pawn this situation
a check like this and black will
actually lose
but I was seeing a physician where
um you know what position was I even
seeing something like this
yeah I was seeing a position like this
where even if we lose the pond we go
here take our position and it will be a
draw like this I did a video covering
this idea how to promote a pawn and goes
into these little details with taking
our position direct opposition the case
where there is exactly one square
separating
the Kings Kings on the same file one
square right between them so I knew that
that was a draw your King takes pawn and
have to run it like this making a king
move allows the king to go here and the
king to take the pawn and because black
always has a pawn move in reserve
there's no way to take opposition
so we need to pitch both phones
back-to-back moves and then play kingi
one going to H 2 allows black to take
opposition opposition black takes
opposition again and then we get
outflanked and we're just cooked from
here the panel promote
a puzzle you have to play g6 you have to
play f5 and then you must play the g1
and then you must play to f1 going here
allows that
here allows that
whoops
yeah going to this square allows that
and going to h2 allows that you have to
avoid these scenarios so g1f one and
take opposition when the King approaches
think it happened like that in the
puzzle and then it was solved how it
would play out is something like this if
you're unfamiliar King backs up if you
must retreat your Ichi to the same file
square as the pawn and you're not going
to have an issues opposition push and
the next move will either be King takes
pawn or stalemate okay
well interesting group of three - King
and pawn end games 1st and 3rd feel free
to share how you did with these in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you
[Music]